hey folks this josh starting rich farmer
welcome to the farm vlog today today is
going to be pretty fun we're gonna be
installing more solar lights and I know
what you're thinking do you really need
more solar lights on the farm well yes
we do so we have a little bit of a
predator problem down at the chicken
coop
something's been digging and scratching
around and trying to get in the chicken
coop at night I've got some pretty
heavy-duty wire on there but I want to
deter those predators from coming and
what deters a predator more than being
discovered ok so we're going to be
installing these 100 whip LED light
fixtures on the outside of the chicken
coop they're all solar panel
self-contained very very simple design
they have a hundred LED lights and we'll
go into more detail about what they do
and how they do but the first thing we
got to do is we're gonna set them out
here in the sunlight and let them charge
for about five hours guys and we'll see
you in just a minute we'll install these
new solar lights all right so folks the
first thing you need to know is this
thing comes with a little pin this
little pin I guess they call it the key
the instruction manual which I'm not
really good about reading tells you what
you have to do with this pin so first
thing you do is unbag it and it has a
protective layer here you peel that
protective layer off of that solar panel
look how pretty that solar panel is then
there's a little power switch right in
there and you take your little pin stick
it in there and you push the power
button and it clicks and it's on pretty
cool
now what I've learned is it has two
positions it's an up position that
sticks out a little more and a down
position down is on it needs to be on in
order to receive a charge and we're
gonna sit them in the bright sunlight
right here right in the driveway right
where it's gonna get plenty of sunlight
okay and we're gonna let them charge for
I don't know two three hours so things
says five hours should get about four or
five hours of direct sunlight but we'll
see I hope this will be the solution to
keep the critters away from our garden
and away from our chicken coop now our
chicken coop is right beside our garden
down there so we can use them and you
were on the garden will see this company
sent me a huge huge discount code for
this thing it's like 50% off so guys if
you're interested in getting a
solar light if you're ever thinking
about getting one of these for outside
your house or for an area that doesn't
have electricity like your barn or
something like that this is the time to
get it 50 percent off of this thing and
it was pretty cheap to start with so
some of the specs on it it says it's
2000 lumens 4.8 watts and it's about 10
inches by 7 inches fairly small fits
right on my t-shirt and covers up that
keeping it Dutch shirt right there just
a little shout-out for my buddy Dutch so
we've got five or six of these things
all over the farm we've got them on our
farm gate we've got them on the house
we've got them all over in places that
we don't want to run wires for light and
they're just handy and it's half off so
the deal was with the company I said you
can send me these lights but you've got
to pass on some sort of savings to my
subscribers so they knock 50 percent off
that's all I have for you now something
I've learned about being a youtuber for
the past two years here is that people
don't like brand placement they don't
like product placement they don't like
it when you show things like wd-40 they
don't like that stuff like wd-40 I don't
like to do a lot of product placements
in my videos part of being a youtuber
sometimes is doing stuff like this and
passing on savings to my subscribers so
I hope you appreciate it and don't think
it's something stupid by the way guys
this light will not serve as a
substitute for the most sold rifle in
America the pain it will not serve as a
substitute for that just so you know the
thought process here is to take this
thing as high as I possibly can but I
don't want the eaves to be hanging over
top of the solar panel okay and I've
charged these for about 30 minutes or so
right now and then they're lighting up
just fine so I'm pretty impressed I
think I'll be very happy with these all
right so we went up to the barn and we
got the ladder now you might notice my
ladder is a little different than your
ladder might be I have towels wrapped
around the end of the ladder right here
and that's so I don't scratch up the
paint on the house or scratch up the
paint on the building just take some
towels and duct tape them around there
they last you about six or eight months
as long as you keep it dry to last
forever and that way you don't beat up
your building we brought our level and
we brought our light now we're going to
take our light and down it up make sure
it's nice and level
pretty close to the center right here
okay pretty simple just gonna kind of
mount it up right there it's gonna drive
me crazy but I'm gonna do it off-center
[Music]
take my level make sure I'm nice and
level come down just a hair all right
they're two sided tape trick worked
pretty good we've got some self-tapping
screws we'll go ahead and zip to self
tappers in here now the kit does not
come with self tapping screws it comes
with wood screws or screws where you can
mount it into like the siding or
something like that but it's right here
it's good enough for us cool so folks
Mountain this thing couldn't be any
simpler basically you just have two
screw holes one screw hole here one
screw hole here it comes with some
hardware and a kit with little tiny
screws I want to use some bigger
heavy-duty screws because that's just
the kind of person I am so we're gonna
go ahead and we're gonna install this
guy I don't want to install it right
here I was gonna put it up high but I'm
afraid that the rain water dripping off
on it constantly will run down in here
and cause damage so we're gonna put it
right here now you're wondering are we
gonna get enough sunlight right here you
get the morning Sun right here it'll be
just perfect so very very simple all I'm
gonna do is mount it up here easily
enough I'm gonna put one screw in first
okay and that will hold it in place once
I get that first screw in then we'll put
the level on the top and make sure it's
level
I'll show you guys you're gonna love my
rooster here in a second he is a movie
star he loves the crow when the cameras
on it's pretty funny we're gonna go
ahead and raise this up and after I put
this up I'll give you a little quick
tour of the chicken coop it's kind of a
mess right now but I'll show you how
it's built anyhow I'll put this up here
slide our level up make sure we're right
on the money okay hold it in place and
then we'll zip our screw in now it's
mounted up nice and sturdy if it doesn't
get enough sunlight right here which I
don't see a problem but if it doesn't
get enough sunlight it's okay I can
always move it it takes two seconds to
move we're going to go ahead and put the
next one over here on the other side of
the coop I'll show you so the next one
is going to go right up there okay we're
going to
it right on the eaves alright so we'll
back right up here with the Gator and
that way we can just hop right up on the
Gator right here and get the job done
there we go
that's simple that's simple to install
guys let me walk you around the chicken
coop and tell you a little bit about it
case you want some ideas for your own
chicken coop so we were thinking
predators the whole time when we built
this coop this right here is another
solar panel it's got a little dust on
the top of it but these little lights
light up on all four corners of the coop
and also they light up the outside of
the coop right here too so these little
solar panels little lights this is a
eight by eight enclosure there's about
fifteen chickens in there and basically
we used heavy-duty wire so that nothing
could get through it in the inside we
have two bolts and it's a mess in here
guys I just want to let you know but in
here we have the place where the
chickens can roost and we have our
nesting boxes and we have our food which
is supported by a chain up in the
ceiling and that's poop now the design
of the coop is such that I can pull this
board straight up and pull my
wheelbarrow which is stored under here
right up underneath it and rake out the
poop into the wheelbarrow and take it to
the garden so here on the outside are my
nesting boxes I think they're eight
nesting boxes maybe more have a little
hook here we unhook the hook we raise it
up and inside our little laying boxes
okay and then we've mounted a light
right here a little push button light so
if we get eggs up in the dark we've got
light and here's our outside chicken run
you can also see I have lots of lights
around here to help deter predators from
getting in the chicken coop and really I
haven't had any troubles hardly at all
except for the last little bit and I'm
not so sure that one of the neighbors
critters might be trying to get in there
like a dog that's it it's a pretty fun
little chicken coop there's an eight by
eight outside run for the chickens will
open the door and let them run through
the garden run through the yard
sometimes and we have the laying boxes
and we have a four by eight little area
for them to hang out and roost well
folks thanks a whole lot for watching
the vlog today I appreciate you I just
want to show you some cool products show
you a cool chicken coop show you what
we've got going on on the farm today got
small projects
going on right now while we wait for our
new 30 acres of grass to start sprouting
over here and it's starting to sprout so
he's a ham guys be sure you click the
like button subscribe to the channel if
you haven't already subscribed and click
the little bell down there don't notify
it when I post a new video share this
with your friends if you know anybody
want some lights like this on the
outside of their house for security or
somebody who'd want them on the outside
of their barn or their shed let them
know about it 50% off can't beat that
right across here I'll have a little
scrolling code for you and we'll come
back right after dark and show you how
good the lights are alright thanks a lot
guys and we'll see you next time on
Stoney Ridge farm
[Music]
Piron sweet add some ways those Denise
Tony Reed
alright guys so we're gonna test out the
light I promised you a good test and
here we are the lights on the chicken
coop right here and we just block out a
little light right here and though thing
is really really bright 2000 lumens 100
LED lights very very impressive very
impressive thanks a lot guys we'll see
you next time
no nuts please thank you guys know maybe
yeah I almost fell down I really like
shiny stuff